i'm a good actor oh and i'm a black man
there's a lot of pride in that but i'm a
good actor roger you're sitting on a
chair you've got leeds castle in with my
name on it right right
mr mosley in front of leeds council in
front of leeds castle this is in many
ways a long journey from a boy who grew
up in watts los angeles you better
believe i got to say hi to my friends
and while i'm living back here right now
you know
i got to assume that somewhere great
decisions were made in that castle king
henry viii castle and
sometime about the slave trade and
everything and now here i am a black man
living in leeds castle
playing chaka khan tapes in there that's
got to be wonderful
this i take it is a kind of thing which
wouldn't have ended into your fancies
when you're a 14 or 15 year old boy it
would never have crossed my mind that i
would be in this setting
it's great i'm having a ball
mind you
you know what john
being from watts i tried poverty from
the for the longest
but uh somehow i've adjusted to wealth
without even half trying you know
it didn't take long for me to learn how
to enjoy this
butler's coming in and giving you the
best of everything this is great i'm
having a ball hello mom
how do you get into the action of the
story my face i am heaviest listen to
the birds and all of this i mean i'm
doing this interview but i'm having a
bar here in london but go on what
[Laughter]
you've had five seasons of magnum you're
going into a sixth why has this
adventure program lasted so long
i think it's because we have had
something to offer everyone we have the
international flavor of the islands the
asian flavor and then
the tropical atmosphere great sights to
see
we've because of tc's helicopter we've
had the mobility to be in different
places and see them from a nice scenic
point of view we've had we've got the
dogs the lads for animal lovers we have
myself for black people we have john for
the europeans we have uh magnum for the
ladies and rick for the young at heart
so i think we got the cars for those
people who like to speed around we have
the vanagon for the more conservative
drivers i think if you go through our
whole show we have a little bit of
everything for everyone and our show is
not a hardcore cops and robbers show we
do a lot of stuff tongue-in-cheek we
have our serious moments and so because
of the texture of the whole show we're
able to present a lot of different
situations
in a different way i think that's been
our appeal to be able to be diversified
how did that sound that sound nice and
technical did it sounded smooth and
unarticulated but i got that all out
without a uh and a hero
like i've said this before
you